le taux d'intérêt des livrets d'épargné
à va-t-il passer de 6,5 à 7 5% le
gouvernement ne l'a pas encore décidé
mais apparemment 6 5% pour les irp et
reniant ce n'est plus assez dans la
période actuelle
la preuve en janvier et en février la
collecte des caisses d'epargne a diminué
de moitié par rapport à la même période
de l'année dernière
jean claude renoult six et demi pour
cent d'intérêt même exonérés d'impôt
pour le livret a
ce n'est plus assez pour deux raisons 1
parce que l'inflation avoisine 12 % 2
parce que les taux du crédit pratiqués
par les banques dépassent 15 % il est
vrai que depuis dix ans l'écart se
creuse entre d'une part le taux
d'inflation
c'est la ligne du haut et d'autre part
la rémunération des livrets ou des
comptes sur livret les deux lignes du
bas regardez en 1970
l'écart était d'un point seulement 4 à 4
25% pour l'épargnant 5% pour l'inflation
il grandit ensuite jusqu'à l'accident
pétrolier de 74 15,2 pour son inflation
6 ennemis pour cent d'intérêt pour les
livret d'epargne 5 75 % seulement pour
les comptes sur livrets des banques mais
avec pour ceux ci une prime éventuelle
de un ennemi pour cent ensuite l'écart
se maintient à peu près de 75 à 77 et
depuis il se creuse régulièrement
conclusion faire passer le taux
d'intérêt des caisses d'epargne de 6
ennemis à cet ennemi pour cent ne serait
qu'un léger rattrapage
mais pour le gouvernement pas question
d'indexer l'epargne sur l'inflation
au contraire il faut l'orienter vers des
placements longs comme les actions les
obligations ou les comptes à terme qui
profitent davantage à l'industrie cela
dit le coup de frein à l épargne liquide
est préoccupant les caisses d'epargne
finances en effet beaucoup
d'investissement elle prête par exemple
aux offices hlm et aux collectivités
locales
[Musique]